32 meses encerrada en un búnker en
azores tal de tiana trot shayk disfruta
de su primer día de libertad bañado por
el sol esa polilla escapar y estar bajo
el cielo tranquilo mira lo azul y
brillante
es pacífico gracias a dios no hay
sonidos de explosiones espero que acá
nunca haya ningún tipo de estruendo solo
fuegos artificiales y truenos pierre
bergé y máximo un grow junto a su marido
y sus padres de tiendas se refugió en
uno de los búnkeres de la acería de
azotar fuertemente bombardeada por rusia
una realidad que compartió con más de 50
personas incluidos niños de los cuales
solo sabe de 14 que han logrado escapar
las drogas terán estoy terriblemente
preocupada por los civiles y los
soldados heridos que siguen allí hasta
más tarde
están más tales del año en estándar al
pasar por la planta anteayer vimos que
todo el día en un monegro como muchas
otras familias la detención a tuvo que
algunas de sus pertenencias y huir
a un refugio cuando un proyectil cayó
cerca de su casa en marzo recibiendo
tuvimos una reunión familiar y decidimos
que algo malo estaba pasando lo mejor
era que nos fuéramos a un lugar más
alejado mi madre trabajaba en la planta
de as hostal en el departamento de
ferrocarriles sabía que ya había un
refugio antibombas en el edificio
administrativo boca de administración de
apretado y cuerpos las autoridades
calculan que al menos 200 civiles siguen
atrapados en los búnkeres de la fábrica
de acero diariamente son muchas personas
de mariupol que llegan a favor y ya en
busca de su relativa seguridad